Ich würde gerne jetzt mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, gerne.
So erst, ich benötige Ihre Personaldaten. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Manfred Müller.
Ich möchte Ihre Vor- und Nachnamebuch stabilen, um sichere gehen.
Ich heiße Manfred.
Ich habe hier El nicht erwähnt, vielleicht mit El, ja?
Okay. Müller mit zwei El, ne?
Müller mit zwei El richten.
Okay. Wie alt sind Sie denn, Herr Müller?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
Könnten Sie mir Ihre Geburtstatung verraten?
Ich bin geboren am 13. März 1967.
Gut. Wie viel wiegen Sie so sein?
Ungefähr 90 Kilo.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
3,76 m.
76?
Ja.
Herr Müller, was kann ich für so tun?
Also, ich weiß nicht genau, wie ich das schildern soll.
Irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl, manchmal, wenn ich so treppen laufe,
oder wenn ich mich so ein bisschen bewege, dann kriege ich so Hitzeballungen,
Kopfschmerzen.
Und ich muss mich dann hinsetzen.
Ich weiß nicht, was damit mir los ist.
Okay. Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
So, das hat angefangen ungefähr vor zwei, drei Monaten.
Und jetzt wird es immer mehr.
Okay. Außer diese Kopfschmerzen haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Nee. Wie gesagt, manchmal habe ich das Gefühl,
dass ich dann auch so zu durchfälle, Michael.
Das ist alles.
Wie meinen Sie durchfälle?
Ich komme mit so wesentlicher Stuhlgang.
Okay. Haben Sie Bauchschmerzen oder
Busschmerzen auch gleichzeitig?
Nee, Bauchschmerzen oder Bussschmerzen habe ich nicht gehabt.
Okay.
Gut.
Fühlen Sie sich über Öbelkeit oder müssen Sie Erbrechen übergeben?
Nein, freulicherweise habe ich das nicht.
Okay. Herr Müller, könnten Sie mir Ihre
vorgegeschichte Erkrankungen etwas sagen,
leider unter irgendwelchen chronischen Krankheiten?
Also, bei mir sind bisher keine Erkrankungen bekannt.
Ich war auch nie beim Arzt gewesen.
Also, nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente oder Beiber da?
Nee, weder noch.
Okay. Herr Müller, Sie haben gesagt,
dass Sie ein Kopchmerzen beim Bewegen und
wesentlicher Stuhlgang, ja?
Ja, und wie gesagt, ich habe dann Herzrasen dabei.
Und wenn das kommt, habe ich das Gefühl,
mir ist es sehr, sehr heiß, ich glöde dabei.
Also, die Ersrasen auch gleichzeitig angefangen
oder vorher?
Wenn es kommt, dann kommt alles auf einmal.
Und nach einigen Minuten hat das schon alleine wieder auf.
Okay. Haben Sie Schwinde oder haben Sie bewusst sein verloren?
Mir bewusst sein verloren habe ich bisher nie gehabt,
aber wenn du etwas kommst, dann rast mir mein Herz
und ich habe das Gefühl, mein Kopf plackst dann.
Okay. Haben Sie irgendwann einmal Ihre Blutdruck gemessen?
Nee, leider nicht.
Okay. Entschuldigung, ich möchte diese Gespräche kurz unterbrechen
und Ihre Vitalparameter, Vitalwerte überprüfen, ja?
Vielleicht Sie haben Blutdruck, ja?
Und Sie haben keine Brustschmerzen, aber wie gesagt,
ich möchte sicherzugehen und Ihre eine EKG schreiben.
Okay? Ja, sehr gut.
Okay. Und wir können jetzt weitergehen,
aber wie gesagt, Sie haben die Ausfälligungen,
haben Sie das gewissensiv?
Ich will noch mal.
Bitte?
Ich will Sie nicht verstehen.
Also, vielleicht Sie können sagen, also ich habe,
nee, egal, also, ja, Herr Müller,
ich habe Ihre Vitalparameter überprüft
und ausfällig etwas Blutdruck gefunden, oder?
Weil wie gesagt, ich habe das nicht immer,
sondern das kommt manchmal so unerwartet.
Wenn ich mich ein bisschen bewege oder erzept steige,
dann ist es plötzlich da,
jetzt momentan fühle ich mich gut momentan.
Okay.
Herr Müller, haben Sie Fieber, Schütterfrost, Nachschweiß?
Nee, kann ich mich jetzt nicht daran erinnern.
Okay. Haben Sie bemerkt manchmal, dass Sie kalte Schweiß haben?
Wie gesagt, es kommt nur, wenn es so ein Tackle ist,
sage ich mir, ich beschreib das Müll als Attacke.
Wenn es mal kommt, dann ist vieles nachher.
Ich glühre mein Herz, und ich habe Kopfschmerzen
und ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich dann so ein bisschen nass geschwitzt habe.
Aber dann hört es wieder drauf.
Okay. Also, manchmal haben Sie keine Bauchschmerzen, ne?
Nein, keine Bauchschmerzen.
Okay. Haben Sie, wie ist die Repetit? Hat sich verandert?
Repetit hat sich nicht verändert.
Okay. Also, westliche Stuhl, außer westliche Stuhl.
Haben Sie Blut da drinnen gesehen?
Blut im Stuhl, meint Sie?
Ja, Blut im Stuhl.
Habe ich nicht beobachtet, nein.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen auch gefallen, dass Sie manchmal während diese Herzgrasen
und Kopfschmerzen, dass Ihre Gesicht etwas gerötet?
Ich habe mich im Spiegel nicht beobachtet, das weiß ich kann sein,
weil ich mich sehr, sehr heiß fühle in dem.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihre Schlafen?
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Einschlafen oder durchschlafen?
Nein, also mit dem Einschlafen oder durchschlafen habe ich kein Problem.
Also, fühlen Sie sich erschoffen und Müdigkeit? Haben Sie Müde?
Nein, kann ich eigentlich nicht sagen.
Ich bin immer noch berufstätig und ich bin immer noch tief.
Okay. Haben Sie Probleme bei dem Wasserlassen?
Nein, nicht.
Okay.
Herr Müdder, wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, den Blindarm, das man mehr mal rausbindern, als Kind,
aber sonst keine Operation.
Und dann haben Sie gesagt?
Blindarm.
Ja, Blindarm, okay.
Außer Blindarm-Operation, haben Sie noch anderes?
Nein, sonst nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Allergie gegen etwas oder Unverträglichkeit?
Ja, bisher nicht.
Okay.
Herr Müdder, sind Sie vollständig geimpft? Ich meine gegen Corona und die Kindheit?
Ja, der Kind hat sowieso alles geeltern, alles gemacht, was da empfohlen war.
Und gegen Corona bin ich dreimal geimpft.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Ferner Reise durchgeführt?
Ich meine, so lange Reise gemacht?
Je, also seit der Corona-Pandemie war ich nicht mehr im Wasser.
Okay.
Herr Müdder, sind Sie sportlich?
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Also ich bin jetzt nicht regelmäßig der Sportmann.
Ich spiele mit Freunden hin und wieder Fußball und fahre mit der Arbeit.
Wie oft haben Sie gesagt?
Im Fahrrad, hier fünfmal am Wochenende, zur Arbeit.
Herr Müdder, ich möchte jetzt über Ihre Familienstand etwas verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin frei.
Leben Sie zusammen mit Ihrem Erlebau?
Ich muss meiner Frau leben zusammen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, eine Tochter und einem Sohn.
Sind Sie gesund?
Und Ihnen geht es gut. Gott sei Dank.
Gott sei Dank.
Was machen Sie als beruflich, Herr Müdder?
Ich bin Informatiker.
Sind Sie so frieden mit Ihrem Büro?
Ja, das war mein Wunschprobe.
Ich wollte schon immer werden.
Das macht mir immer noch lecker.
Herr Müdder, sind Ihre Eltern am Leben?
Ja, die sind noch im Leben.
Gut, das ist gut.
Sind Sie gesund oder leiden Sie unter irgendwelche chronischen Krankungen?
Mein Vater hat ein bisschen Diabetes, ein bisschen Blutdruck.
Meine Mutter erzählt das von Schilddrüsenknoten.
Sie sind in welchen Schilddrüsenhormonen.
Bei ihr hat man auch ein bisschen Blutdruck festgestellt.
Ich habe nicht verstanden, welche Schilddrüsenprobleme hat Ihre Mutter.
Unterfunktion oder überfunktion?
Nein, keine. Sie hat nur Knoten in der Schilddrüse.
Nur Knoten und festgestellt, aber das funktioniert nicht normal.
Ja.
Gut, haben Sie Bruder, Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe noch eine jüngere Schwester.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, sie ist aufgesucht.
Herr Müller, rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Trägen Sie Alkohol?
Nein, mit Alkohol vertreiben Sie nicht.
Ich trinke kein Alkohol.
Sie haben eine Routinefrage, haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drohren?
In der Jugend habe ich mal ein bisschen Haschisch geraucht, aber seitdem nicht mehr.
Herr Müller, hätten Sie ähnliche Beschwerden vorher gehabt?
Oder ist das für Sie neue?
Das sind neue Beschwerden.
Das sind neue?
Das sind neue, seit zwei, drei Monaten.
Sind Sie beschwerden, wenn Sie sich verandern?
Ich meine, so vermehrt?
Oder lindert?
In den letzten Wochen wird es häufiger, aber es sind ungefähr dieselben Beschwerden.
Anfangs kamen Sie vielleicht mal alle zwei, drei Wochen.
Ich bin nicht mehr sicher, diese Frage habe ich Ihnen gestellt.
Hat Ihre Gehüchle in der Lösterzeit sich verändert?
Haben Sie ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, ich habe nicht zugenommen. Gewicht ist gleich geblieben.
Okay.
Herr Müller, Sie haben eine Frage,
ob Sie etwas hinzufügen oder Fragen haben?
Nein, ich möchte nur, dass ich etwas draussen mache,
weil das macht mir schon ein bisschen Sorgen.
Ja, okay.
Also, wie gesagt, es ist früher etwas zu sagen.
Sie haben seit zwei, drei Monaten
Kopfschmerzen beim Bewegung und wässrige Stuhl.
Zuerst muss ich Ihre körperliche Untersuchung danach
Blut abnehmen und verschiedene Bildgebende Verfahren durchführen.
Danach kann ich Ihnen sagen,
oder richtige Bescheid geben, was Sie genau haben.
Also, so seit, ich bin mir leid,
und ich möchte früher,
jetzt haben Sie richtige etwas nehmen,
weigeln.
Okay, gut.
Okay.
Also, möchten die anderen Kollegen etwas hinzufügen
oder fragen?
Meine Rolle, Ali.
Ja.
Das ist meine Rolle. Ich bin Moderator.
Ja, bitte.
Ich habe meine Kollegen und meine Kollegen noch andere Fragen.
Herr Kollege, können Sie die Stuhlgang genau beschreiben,
wie oft Ihre Dusche verlesst,
und wie sieht aus Ihre Stuhlgang und Basalasen?
Also, mit dem Basalasen ist kein Problem.
Wie gesagt, wenn diese Attacke kommt
mit Kopfschmerzen, Herzhasen und so,
als wenn ich glöhe, dann muss ich auf Toilette rennen.
Und dann ist der Stuhlgang zwar normal,
aber es sieht ziemlich dünn aus in dem Fall.
Wie oft kommt es zu dieser Attacke?
Ja, wehen.
Am Anfang alle zwei bis drei Wochen einmal,
und jetzt in einer Woche zwei bis drei Wochen.
Ja.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihr Haut oder Augen gelbisch gefordert
oder blesse gefordert?
Nein, also im Spiegel habe ich keine Gelbverwaltung bemerkt.
Nein.
Wenn kein Fibar, kein Gewicht fährlört, kein Nachschweiß,
kein Schmuck.
Nein, nicht wenn ich,
Dispino, Sephagia, Melanom, Durcheval,
Takikardi, Vertigo.
Takikardi haben wir schon, ja.
Takikardi haben wir schon.
Takikardi mit Belastung auftreten.
Ein leichter Fall, leichter Belastung.
Kommt es zu dieser Übung?
Ja, leichter Belastung.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, aber vielleicht ist es nicht so.
Ja, ich spreche wieder.
Ja, könnte wir als erstes ein bisschen anfangen?
Ja, sehr, sehr weniger Symptome.
Allician, bitte.
Okay.
Schönen guten Tag, Herr Oberst.
Ich möchte einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Hätten Sie großer Zeit für mich?
Hallo, hören Sie mich?
Herr Oberst.
Ja, haben Sie mich nicht gehört?
Nein.
Nein, hören Sie mich jetzt?
Ja, jetzt höre ich.
Ich glaube, mein Kopf gehört sich jetzt zu Abschiedes.
Das muss immer gerade ausschalten.
Also, hören Sie mich jetzt?
Ja, ganz gut.
Und klar.
Hören Sie mich jetzt?
Ja, pananen, okay.
Ich fange.
Guten Morgen, Herr Oberst.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Und ich würde gerne Ihnen diesen Patienten vorstellen.
Hätten Sie großer Zeit für mich?
Ja, gerne.
Also, Herr Malphret Müller ist ein 56-Jähriger-Patient.
Und 13.
war es 1967 geboren.
Er ist seit 90 Kilogramm und 1,66 m groß.
Der Patient habe seit 2-3 Monaten
Belastung Kopfschmerzen und Herzrasen,
Wesselgestuhl, schreibt er.
Ich möchte diese Satz wiederholen.
Herr Malphret Müller ist ein 56-Jähriger-Patient,
der sich heute Morgen bei uns aufgrund seit 2-3 Monaten
bestehende Belastung Kopfschmerzen und Wesselgestuhl,
und gleichzeitig Herzrasen vorgestellt hat.
Der Patient berichtet, dass diese alle Symptomen am Anfang
innerhalb 2-3 Monaten, Wochen einmal erlebt.
Aber im Laufe der Zeit, Wochen nicht 2-3 Mal erlebt.
Der Patient hat mit uns Zeit,
dass er kaum Begleitzentrums haben, außer dass ich erzählt habe,
die fragen nach Fieber-Apertitlosigkeit, Fieber-Inapartenz,
Gehwischveränderung, also Hyperhydrosis in der Nacht
wohl der Vernein.
Er habe vor Erkrankungen keine Erkrankungen.
Er nehmt keine Medikamente ein.
Er wurde in Kindheit nur einmal apalysiert.
Er ist operiert und hat keine Anlege oder Unverträglichkeit.
Er hat gegen Corona 3-mal geimpft.
Er ist auch durchgeführt, er sei vollständig geimpft.
Er hat seine Familie, seine Familie,
seine Vater,
leider unter Diabetes mellitus und Atariellehypertoni.
Er ist eine gesunde Bruder, Schwester.
Er ist so seit verheiratet und lebt mit seinem Erfrau.
Er hat eine gesunde Sohn und eine Tochter.
Er ist Informatiker und sei zufrieden mit seinem Beruf.
Er war ein Nichtraucher und weder Alkohol noch Zigarre.
Nikotin.
Er habe keine Kontakte mit dem Drogen.
Man kann auch sagen, Drogenkonsum wird verneint.
Ich habe den Patienten mit Vitalkarameten gemessen.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich gefunden habe.
Vielleicht habe ich einen Bluthochdruck.
An die anderen müsste ich einen Angaben deuten am ehesten.
Karxineuzentrum, wie Poma,
Erdobene,
eine hormonechromane Erkrankung.
Sie haben ihn untersucht,
wie hoch der Blutdruck war.
180 bis 70.
Er hat gesagt, er fühlt sich momentan gut.
Er wird maximal nur 140 bis 80 Blutdruck.
Im EKG haben sie nichts Auffälliges gesehen.
Sie haben Blut abgenommen.
Sehen Sie da etwas?
Nein, es kann nicht sein.
Er hat keine Anämie.
Im Blut sehen Sie nichts Auffälliges.
Das Ganze sieht völlig blander aus.
Das Einzige, das Ihnen so auffällt,
ist, dass der LDH leicht erhöht ist.
Okay.
Jetzt müssen wir Schritt für Schritt weitergehen.
Was würden Sie als nächstes machen?
Ich möchte diese Patienten körperlich schon zu sehr tun.
Ich fange in den Aspektsion,
danach Palpassion, Aspektation und Percussion weiterführen.
Bei Aspektsion möchte ich den Patienten beobachten.
Es gibt eine Blutverfaltung.
Man kann eine Belästchen sehen.
Wenn es eine Belähung gibt,
dann lassen wir uns die Patienten erst mal heran.
Sie haben eine Arbeit, Hypothese.
Sie denken, dass es etwas hormonelles ist.
Der Patient hat geschildert,
dass diese Attacke bei leichtester Belastung kommt.
Sie gehen mit dem Mann auf die Reise,
treppensteigen oder auf dem Ergometer.
Sie beobachten ihn.
Sie gehen mit dem Mann auf den Ergometer,
weil es auf der Station einen Ergometer gibt.
Treppensteigen oder Ergometer.
Bitte noch mal.
Treppensteigen.
Man kann auch Treppensteigen oder Fahrrad-Ergometer benutzen.
Wissen Sie, was ein Fahrrad-Ergometer ist?
Ja.
Ein Fahrrad, das sich nicht fort bewegt,
sondern wo man einfach an der Stelle tritt.
Das ist ein Ergometer.
Sie nehmen auf den Ergometer und sagen, das möchte ich sehen.
Sie überwachen ihn.
Sie kontrollieren seinen Blutdruck.
Sie beobachten ihn und wollen einmal sehen, was passiert.
Sie lassen ihn 5-10 Minuten radeln,
bis ein Kreislauf in Gang kommt.
Und plötzlich sehen sie, der wird knallrot.
Er kriegt eine Fleischsymptomatik.
Sie haben etwas provoziert.
Irgendetwas passiert im Körper.
Er hat eine Fleischproblematik.
Jetzt können Sie aktiv werden.
Was machen Sie als nächstes?
Wir finden ausfällig etwas.
Wir haben die Belastungen testen.
Die nächsten Schritte würde ich an den Patienten Blut abnehmen.
Und die hormonal Profilen schauen.
Hier ist es wichtig, die Träutormonnen,
wie die anderen aufzunehmen.
Und natürlich auch wichtig,
die Adrenalin-Spiegel im Blut.
Woran denken Sie da?
Bei der Bewegung, unter Belastung bekommen die Symptomen mehr.
Das könnte sein, dass eine hormoneaktive Krankheit
oder eine hormone-Blut im Spiel werden.
Beim Belastung verändert sich die Höhe.
Was kennen Sie dann für hormoneaktive Tumore?
Das ist ein etwas tieferer Thema.
Es könnte sein, Neuro.
Es kann ein neuer Indoklinis sein.
Es kann überall liegen.
Es kann ein Lungentumor sein.
Es kann auch im Magen sein.
Oder im Dünndarm oder im Rektum.
Es kann aber auch ein hormoneaktiver Tumor der Nebenniere sein.
Adrenalin, Medulat, eine Karstschlur kann es sein.
Wie nennt man den Tumor von der Nebenniere?
Was hormoneaktiv ist?
Das ist einfache Frage.
Das ist das Pheochromozytom.
Sie haben eine Flasche-Symptomatik.
Dann schicken Sie den Mann zum Ultraschall.
Dann gucken Sie, ob Sie in der Sonografie im Bauchraum erkennen.
Das ist der Mann.
Der Mann wird geschallt.
Dann sieht man an der linke Nebenniere,
ungefähr 2 cm großen Tumor.
Es steht in den rechten Nebennieren.
Ja, in der rechten Nebenniere.
Also es kann, jetzt haben Sie ein Verdacht,
dass es ein hormoneaktiver Tumor der Nebenniere ist.
Das kann ein Pheochromozytom sein.
Jetzt müssen Sie die Diagnostik vorantreiben.
Was wäre der nächste Schritt?
Das kann man so blieben.
Was würden Sie als Chirurg erwarten,
bevor Sie so einen Menschen operieren?
Ich habe eine Reisefasche im Patienten.
Ich schaue den Urin-Testern.
Die Katakulamin-Spiegern im Urin.
Kennen Sie da wie Herr Kadek?
Wie Emma, Emma T.
Und natürlich im Blut auch.
Katakulamin-Spiegern.
Im Blut werden hier bestimmte Dinge getestet.
Also 3 Sachen sollte man schon testen.
Und Abbauprodukte, im Urin vor allem.
3 Tage sammelt Urin.
Und Sie können natürlich auch im Blut Katakulamine messen.
Sie können auch Cortisol-Spiegeln messen.
Aber im Urin ist vor allem wichtig,
dass Sie Katakulamine und Abbauprodukte bestimmen lassen.
Dann sehen Sie, ob der zu bestimmten Zeiten aktiv ist oder nicht.
Ein bestimmter Parameter, der hier bestimmt wird,
ist das 5-Hydroxy-Indole-Sx-Säure.
5-H-I-E-S.
5-Hydroxy-Indole-Sx-Säure.
Abbauprodukte von dem Katakulamin.
Ein Abbauprodukt der Katakulamine.
Das kann man sehr gut im Urin bestimmen.
Dann können Sie daraus schließen, ob der tatsächlich Hormon aktiv ist.
Warum müssen Sie das machen?
Was ist der Grund dafür?
Das Hormon aktiv ist, können wir so lernen.
Das heißt, ein Körper gibt aktiven Hormonen
und sie ausscheiden in dem.
Aber aus chirurgischer Sicht.
Unsere Chorgen sagen,
das muss alles vor einer Operation kontrolliert sein.
Warum?
Während der Operation kann etwas lebensgefährlicher folgen.
Was ist denn die Gefahr dabei?
Das ist während der Operation erhöhte Bluthochdruck.
Manchmal werden sie den Kanoten- oder Tümoren berühren.
Dann erhöhte die Bluthochdruck.
Sehr gefährlich kann sein.
Und lebendetruchlich kann sein.
Deswegen ist das gefährliche Situation.
Genau, das ist auch der Punkt.
Deshalb hat der Patient bei Belastung diese Problematik,
diese Symptome entwickelt.
Der ist nicht so sehr groß, der Tumor.
2 cm ist jetzt nicht sehr riesig.
Wenn der Treppen steigt,
wenn der Muskulator aktiviert,
die Nieren in Bewegung kommt,
löst es die Humorausschüttung aus.
Dadurch bekommt er diese Fleischsymptomatik.
Oder diese Durchfallsymptomatik.
Das war sein Grund.
Ansonsten macht so ein Pheokromo zu Tum.
Meistens überhaupt keine Beschwerden.
Darum geht es.
Jetzt haben wir die Humor bestimmt.
Man sieht, dass 5 Hiis hoch ist.
Man sieht auch, dass die Kategorlamine hoch sind.
Und sie haben die Gewissheit,
der Mann muss ein Pheokromo zu Tum haben.
Aber zur Sicherheit sollten sie nochmal ein MRT machen.
Ein MRT vom Abdomen, von den Nebennieren.
Wonach müssen sie dann noch schauen?
Sie müssen mal gucken, ob er eine Nierenarterie
in Stenose noch hat oder nicht.
Das kann manchmal auch ein Problem werden.
Bei der Operation, soweit ich das mitbekommen habe.
Hierurg sind Sie, aber unsere Hierurgen sagen dann immer,
bitte die Gefäßsituation mitkontrollieren lassen.
Nicht, dass wir dann intraoperativ vor einem Problem stehen.
Gut.
Die Mutter hatte angegeben,
die hat so ein Schilddrüsenproblem.
Ich würde auch die Schilddrüsenwerte mitkontrollieren.
Warum?
Weil es gibt ja diese multiple endocrine Neoplasie,
mann abgekürzt.
Nicht, dass er so etwas hat.
Nicht, dass er nicht nur ein Pheokromo zu Tum,
sondern vielleicht auch ein Tumor in der Schilddrüse hat,
das auch hormoneaktiv sein kann.
Einfach mal den Körper nach einem Tumor scannen.
Manchmal gibt es auch die Möglichkeit,
mittlerweile kann man, glaube ich, auch mit einem Pet abklären,
mit irgendetwas Aktives da ist.
Mit einem Dottatet Pet kann man sowas machen, glaube ich.
Aber ob das bezahlt wird, da bin ich überfragt momentan.
Aber die klassische Verfahrensweise ist,
einfach mal ein Ultraschalt gucken, ob man irgendetwas sieht.
Auch wenn man nicht sehen würde,
die Symptomatik spricht für so etwas.
Ein MRT machen und dann kommt man auf diese Tumore,
auf die Schliche.
Und die Symptomatik ist dann schon komplett operiert.
Weil irgendwann kann das Ganze zu einem krisenhaften Problem führen.
Das Herz kann mal akut aussetzen.
Oder irgendwelche Blutungen, Intrazerebral.
Und das könnte Lebensgefällt.
Ja, genau.
Also es muss nicht immer sehr viel.
Ich habe Ihnen so ein Patienten geschildert,
wo Sie so ein bisschen hellhörig werden müssen.
keine Basiomptomatik, aber klassische Beschwerden. Ja, klassische Beschwerden. Ja, und das muss man einfach so
heraushören. Jung, kaum Beschwerden, aber spezifische Beschwerden. Und da müssen sie diesen spezifischen
Beschwerden hinterherlaufen. Gucken, was ist das? Ja, woran kann das hängen? Was ist
die Zusammenhang? Und das plausibelste. Nicht einfach blind hin und her, sondern das war hier einleuchtend
eigentlich. Der Patient hat angegeben, wann fängt das Ganze an? Wie macht sich das bemerkbar? Wenn sie
sonst nichts haben, dann machen sie das doch. Recapitulieren, sagt man ja auch. Wiederholen,
provozieren, damit man das Ganze auch beobachten kann. Der Kardiologe macht ja auch nichts anderes,
wenn jemand sagt, ich kriege Brustschmerzen, wenn ich Fahrrad fahre, dann setzt man sie auf
ein Algometer und dann gucken wir mal, was man im EKG sieht. Ja, genau. Gut, also Urin,
Kategorlamine plus Abbauprodukte, Serum im Blut, auch die Spiegelbestimmungen und noch eine
Wilddieber. Ja, ja. Und ansonsten dem Patienten gut aufklären, dass er vorsichtig sein soll bis
zur Operation und der muss dann operiert werden. Wie das Ganze rein technisch abläuft, da bin ich
überfragt, ich bin kein Chirurg, da wissen Sie besser, wie das Ganze abläuft. Ja, gut. Soweit
dieses Problem verstanden ist zwar selten, aber es ist schon eine Bekrankung, die hin und
wieder mal zu einem kommen kann und es ist häufig internistisches Problem, solche Leute gehen nicht
direkt zum Chirurgen, aber hin und wieder landet sowas auch mal direkt bei den Chirurgen und dann
sagen sie, ja, wir haben so etwas und dann fragen sie uns, was sollen wir da alles machen? Dann
sagen wir ja, das und das und das und dann wird er dann operiert. Natürlich kann es sein, so etwas
mir auch passieren kann sein natürlich. Ja, klar, klar. Gibt es denn von den anderen diesbezüglich
irgend eine Frage oder etwas, was sie nicht verstanden haben oder wo sie denken,
dass es nicht so ausreichend ist? Liebe Kollegen. Hat jemand mal mit so einer Erkrankung mal zu tun
nicht nichts. Herr Gündos, haben Sie schon mal solche Erfragen?
noch nie gehabt. Aber bitte dran denken, ja, man behandelt immer wieder Neuroendocrine
Karzinoma, aber nicht vergessen, dass es auch nebendieren Rinnentumore geben kann und die können
genauso ähnliche Probleme machen mit Flaschsymptomatik und so weiter und da ist es wichtig, dass man
Katicholamine und Katicholamin Abbauprodukte bestimmt, Bildgebung macht und diesen Patienten
der Operation zu finden. Dankeschön. Das war gut.